well it's interesting how this how this
happens you know and this is he told us
I don't think I've told this particular
part of of oh good I did this pilot
called or Kane for CBS Kane I hope this
doesn't jeopardize my role on Lost yeah
because we asked we said look I may do
this pilot but if you guys offer us
something just even a six minimum
episode thing I won't do the pilot
because I want to preserve this on lost
because you know I mean I love the role
they wouldn't do that we just don't know
we can't I remember Landing in Hawaii
and I remember telling Jack Bender I go
don't kill me off do not kill me off on
the show I don't know that this Pilot's
gonna get picked up so I please don't
kill me off and sure enough it gets
picked up and they don't kill me off and
I'm like oh no no I mean I'm like now
wow I hope I didn't put the show in a
pickle but you know but not your fault
but it's now you know so not my fault I
get the other side of it you know yeah
it's just the business it's just it's
just the nature of it and until you
learn leverage you you don't know what
you know what you have